Every film has its fair share of deleted scenes
— and while most of the time they tend to
be inconsequential, from time to time, a movie
can actually be ruined by leaving the wrong
moments on the cutting room floor.
Here's a look at some major releases whose
editing put a major dent in everyone's enjoyment.
The Golden Compass
After the astounding critical and commercial
success of Peter Jackson's Lord of the Rings
trilogy in the early 2000s, New Line Cinema
tried to recapture that glory with another
fantasy trilogy: Philip Pullman's His Dark
Materials.
It didn't work, since you probably forgot
this movie ever even existed.
The studio hired screenwriter Chris Weitz
to helm an adaptation of the first novel in
the trilogy, The Golden Compass, starring
Daniel Craig, Nicole Kidman, and newcomer
Dakota Blue Richards.
But it was the material that Weitz decided
to leave out of his adaptation that sealed
the franchise's fate.
The book's fans faulted Weitz for his decision
to exclude the novel's overt themes of questioning
religion by hiding them in metaphors.
The film lost the novel's essence along the
way, and was widely ridiculed for softening
a major component of the story in order to
cater to a wider audience.
Furthermore, in order to accommodate a shorter
runtime, Weitz had to cut out an estimated
hour from his original screenplay — mostly
scenes featuring the story's protagonist,
Lyra.
With no support from the fans and general
audiences left scratching their heads, this
would-be trilogy was unsurprisingly halted
after a single chapter.
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
There's no denying that the DC Extended Universe
has been successful at the box office.
However, there's also no getting around the
criticisms that have greeted these movies,
particularly 2016's Batman v Superman: Dawn
of Justice.
Fans and critics alike blasted the movie for
its haphazard editing and confused plot, which
still resulted in a 151 minute punch-stravaganza.
In fact, even with over two-and-a-half hours
worth of film, many felt several plotlines
and characters were underdeveloped.
When editor David Brenner confirmed that the
original cut was almost four hours long, it
became clear that the theatrical version really
was as undercooked as it seemed.
Shortly after the movie's release, the studio
released an R-rated Ultimate Edition, which
added an additional 30 minutes of footage.
Critics have said the extended version is
a drastic improvement, expanding upon Lex
Luthor's role and Clark Kent's investigation.
Maybe Zack Snyder will learn his lesson and
make the Justice League movie the full 14-hour
epic we all know it needs to be.
That was sarcasm by the way, that'd be awful.
Suicide Squad
After the critical disappointment that came
with Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice, fans
hoped Suicide Squad would be a turning point
for the DC Extended Universe.
Too bad it still earned more than its share
of critical scorn.
The unhappiest critic of all?
That was Jared Leto, who played the movie's
new take on the Joker.
Although he doesn't appear too much in the
final cut, Jared Leto claimed to have filmed
an entire movie's worth of footage as the
Joker.
And considering that Batman's arch-nemesis
was such a big draw in the first place, plenty
of people were disappointed when the filmmakers
relegated him to the background — so much
so that some fans have actually attempted
to sue the studio.
Warner Bros.' extended cut of Suicide Squad
added another 13-minutes to the runtime, shining
more light on the relationship between the
Joker and Harley Quinn.
As to whether we'll ever get to see the rest
of the Joker footage that Leto shot is a mystery
that not even Batman can solve.
Nightbreed
Based on the 1988 novel Cabal by director
Clive Barker, Nightbreed follows mental patient
Aaron Boone, who believes he's a serial killer,
as he runs from the police and joins a group
of recluse monsters known as — that's right
— the Nightbreed.
Since he wrote both the source material and
the script, Barker had a clear vision — one
the executives at 20th Century Fox didn't
share.
They wanted a slasher film with scary monsters,
and that wasn't what Barker delivered with
his two-and-a-half hour cut.
In response, the studio ordered a series of
reshoots and cut almost an hour out of the
final product.
In the end, Nightbreed was a critical and
commercial failure, though it did achieve
cult status among hardcore horror fans.
It wasn't until 2014 that a director's cut
saw release, running 20 minutes longer than
the theatrical version and featuring 40 minutes
of altered or unseen footage.
Daredevil
Mark Steven Johnson's Daredevil from 2003
received mixed-to-negative reviews during
its theatrical run, but was still moderately
successful, becoming the second highest-grossing
February release at the time.
Shortly afterward, Johnson put together a
director's cut, which was released the following
year.
It included additional footage that had been
excised from the theatrical version, as well
as an entire subplot featuring a drug addict
named Dante Jackson played by none other than
Coolio.
And, as we learned from the Sci Fi original
movie Pterodactyl, the presence of Coolio
can elevate just about anything.
"You know we can be famous or something."
"Can that nonsense now, soldier!"
While the director's cut went unnoticed by
most, the few who saw it agreed that it turned
what once was a mess into a compelling story.
Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige, who
served as producer on the film, has gone on
record saying, "I think…the people who had
other opinions will be won over by this new
version."
Perhaps if Johnson's cut of the film released
in theaters instead, moviegoers might have
had a different initial opinion of Ben Affleck
when Warner Bros. cast him as the new Batman.
And maybe we'd all be waiting in line for
the latest installment of Coolio's Dante Jackson
spin-off franchise.
Fantastic Four
In 2015, Josh Trank's Fantastic Four remake
released to overwhelming critical discontent,
with the movie winning Razzies for Worst Director,
Worst Remake, Worst Screenplay, and Worst
Picture.
Much of the film's issues have been pinned
on Trank, though he's claimed an exceptional
cut of the film does indeed exist.
But we'll never see it.
One day prior to the movie arriving in theaters,
Trank took to Twitter and responded to the
critical backlash, saying,
"A year ago I had a fantastic version of this.
And it would've received great reviews.
You'll probably never see it.
That's reality though."
Although many people would consider Trank's
tweet to be the rumblings of a disgruntled
director, Toby Kebbell, who plays the villain
Doctor Doom, attested to the same thing, telling
The Daily Beast, "I tell you, the honest truth
is, [Trank] did cut a great film that you'll
never see.
That is a shame.
A much darker version, and you'll never see
it."
As for what we can see?
The wig Kate Mara wore during the movie's
reshoots.
So, you know, win some, lose some.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love!